[Musik]
gewalttätige proteste in barcelona ein
rapper wird wegen seiner texte zum neun
monaten haftstrafe verurteilt und die
lage eskaliert diverse hashtags gehen
wir alle besonders auf twitter und
telegramm rufen viele zum widerstand auf
und wenn die meinungsfreiheit in gefahr
und wo sind die grenzen
ich bin journalist ich bin mit hiphop
aufgewachsen und als der spanische
rapper pablo er selbigen seiner texte in
den knast musste habe ich mir sofort die
frage gestellt ist dass ein spanischer
einzelfall oder kann das auch anders
ich will mit größen der branche sprechen
wie dem deutschen paar mega und musiker
innen finden dem liegen texte
tatsächlich der knast wird aber dazu
später
zuerst für dich verstehen warum es hier
in barcelona nach russells warten so
eskaliert ist online und offline und das
rap damit zu tun und dafür muss ich rein
ins 10 auf instagram entdecke ich die
gruppe la cantera sie sind jung
erfolgreich und scheint gut zu sein
ich fahre ich bin jetzt im süden von
barcelona und treffen gleich ein paar
jungs die dabei sind sich im spanischem
recht ich einen namen zu machen und
dabei kein blatt vor den mund
[Musik]
cantera das heißt so viel wie
talentschmiede auf youtube an ihre
videos millionen views und provokation
mangelt es nicht
im echten leben sie die jungs ganz nett
aber ich merke schnell der frust ist
nicht gespielt
hier fehlt es an perspektiven auf den
straßen von spanien wo die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit fast 40 prozent
beträgt mit rap für sie zum sprachrohr
und der fall
[Musik]
ich glaube dass sich etwas ändern wird
wir sind bewusster geworden
die veränderung war dass wir gesehen
haben dass das jetzt schon realität ist
es kann passieren dass du einen song
schreibst und sie sich deswegen ins
gefängnis stecken
ich glaube der bewusst hat sich geändert
noch mal von vorn was eigentlich
passiert ist
am 16 februar wird der rapper partners
hält der sich in der uni seiner
heimatstadt leider verbarrikadiert hatte
gewaltsam verhaftet der vorwurf
majestätsbeleidigung und verherrlichung
von gewalt
es sind unter anderem zeilen in denen
all könig juan carlos ein parasit mörder
und mafioso net
juan carlos steht wegen zahlreicher
skandale und betrugs ab bern im fokus
viele sehen ihn als symbol für einen
korrupten staatsapparat egal wie man
dazu steht für mich klingt gefängnis für
einen rap text erst mal ziemlich krass
was sagen die jungs von war kein tera zu
musik von pablo slk blue grass selber
keine musik ikone in spanien er war kein
künstler dem alle zuhören wollten oder
der einen wichtigen einfluss auf das
verhalten der menschen und jugendlichen
in spanien hatte das gefühl dass man
hier hat ist dass die regierung ein
exempel statuieren möchte einem anderen
künstler einzuschüchtern
mich persönlich hat er nicht dazu
gebracht mich zu ändern oder aggressiv
gegen die regierung oder die monarchie
vorgehen in spanien spielt die regierung
häufig mit der politik der angst die
menschen gehen auf die straße sie bieten
sind sie zocken will container an oder
prügeln sich mit der polizei falls sie
müde sind
[Musik]
wir verabreden uns für später nochmal im
proberaum dort wollen sie mir dann auch
ein paar ihrer neuen songs zeigen und
auch in dem wird es auch gegen start
gehen mir wird klar die verhaftung von
pablo sl hat ja einmal mehr das fass zum
überlaufen gebracht
einer der gründe der streit um
meinungsfreiheit und der ist nicht neu
schon vor fünf jahren hat die regierung
ein äußerst umstrittenes gesetz
verabschiedet das la motta auf deutsch
knebel gesetz
es soll ein gesetz zum schutz der bürger
in sein so die regierung
ein massiver einschnitt in die
demonstrations- und meinungsfreiheit
finden die gegner unter strafe gestellt
werden können unter anderem das
verbrennen der spanische flagge oder wie
im fall von pablo sl verherrlichung von
gewalt und terror und die beleidigung
der krone
[Musik]
rapper im nutzen ihre texte als
sprachrohr nicht nur in spanien oft sind
es junge menschen die gehört werden
wollen und ganz bewusst grenzen
aber das bleibt wirklich alles nur weil
es kunst ist schwierig wirklich versteht
und schon ziemlich lange und
erfolgreichen geschäft ist haye
sebastian grüßt ich der berliner bekamen
mega low startet seine musikalische
karriere in 19 werden zu der zeit fange
ich an mit zu hören inzwischen ist er
hat hotelier und weiß was die musik als
sprachrohr hausen
du bist eine braune also per definition
ist rap musik eine kunstform in der die
mächtigen kritisiert werden dürfen das
ist einfach das ist die natur dieser
musik und das jetzt sozusagen in frage
zu stellen und da auch dann jemand dafür
ins gefängnis zu schicken dass er quasi
in der kunstfreiheit seine meinung sagt
das halte ich für höchst problematisch
ich würde sagen provokation ist
grundsätzlich teil von kunst und deshalb
sollte es im web auch stattfinden können
gerade schockierende kunst ist irgendwie
die die am meisten was bewirkt rapper
per gesetz zu bestrafen sei der falsche
weg sagt michael o viel mehr bräuchten
wir eine bewusstere gesellschaft es ist
wichtig dass die zuhörer und die ganze
web community der menschen die das
konsumieren dann bewusst darüber sind
und unterscheiden zwischen
diskriminierung und eben nach unten
treten und die stimme kritisch einsetzen
und machtstrukturen in frage zu stellen
diejenigen und training
laut mega low kommt es also darauf an
gegen wen sich rap richtet ob nach unten
getreten wird oder auf machtstrukturen
und die da oben gezählt wird
denn dafür sei die musik sei keines
bekannt als teil von hiphop entwickelt
sich in den 70er jahren in den sozialen
brennpunkten von york sowie der south
bronx
es ist die afro-amerikanische community
die red dafür nutzt im ärger über
soziale missstände und rassismus
ausdruck zu verleihen
das genre ist so quasi von natur aus
politisch zurück zu la cantera ich will
mehr darüber erfahren was die situation
in spanien so besonders macht die jungs
kommen alle aus unterschiedlichen
vierteln aber sie treffen sich fast
jeden tag hier instanz wo sie gemeinsam
die probleme ihres alltags in texten
verpackt
[Musik]
marcel künstlername ist fit er ist der
bekannteste rapper des kollektivs er ist
21 träumt vom großen ein plan b hat er
nicht obwohl mir viel gelacht wird
merkel schnell geht es um die musik ist
[Musik]
einer ihrer bekanntesten songs heißt
generation perdita verlorene generation
und der erfolg zeigt sich eine jugend
von spanien aus der seele zu sprechen
wir fühlen uns in all diese situationen
ein die schwierig sind die wir erlebt
haben wie ein kumpel erlebt hat wir sind
keine gangster aber wir haben was wir
auf der straße sehen vielleicht haben
wir nicht mehr oder weniger straße als
jeder andere aber wir verbringen viel
zeit auf der straße
es geht um das was wir empfinden viele
davon hängt vom system in dem wir leben
ab von der stadt in der wir leben
das beeinflusst weißt du es und
erfahrung die sie mit vielen jungen
spanier in verbünden
ich habe mein ganzes leben lang musik
gemacht und alles getan um geld zu
verdienen
ich steckte schon tief in der scheiße
ich weiß wie es ist wenn es einem
schlecht geht
ich kenne viele leute ich habe viele
situationen gesehen ich hätte nicht für
den der in seiner villa sitzt bruder und
eingemachtes leben hatte ich rappe für
den der in der verdammte scheiße ist und
ich habe in der scheiße gesessen und ich
habe es geliebt und es hat mich so
wütend gemacht für ein beschissenes
gehalt zu arbeiten und für eine firma
die mich abzockt weil die regierung ist
erlaubt weil sie die unternehmer schüsse
und dann gehst du vor gericht und dort
steht ein gekaufter richter dein enkel
von wer weiß wen ist das macht mich
wütend
wir leben in einem so großen land wie es
mir unmöglich ist nicht darüber zu
sprechen
korruption eine monarchie die das letzte
bisschen vertrauen verspielt hat eine
jugend ohne perspektiven und das gefühl
nicht gehört zu werden
zugegeben auch wenn diese dinge für mich
der in einem dorf in westfalen
aufgewachsen ist ziemlich weit weg sind
kann ich den frust der jungs doch
zumindest nachvollziehen
ich glaube 80 prozent meiner generation
wurde eine ganz andere welt versprochen
aber die gibt es nur etwas völlig
anderes bekommen
jetzt sind wir eine generation von
frustrierten und diesem gefühl können
sie durch wenn ich tatsächlich durch
meine musik etwas verändern eine
veränderung
es ist eine super utopische sache dass
mit der veränderung ist ich spreche
nicht von einer veränderung was mir an
dem was du gesagt hast wirklich gefallen
hat vielleicht hast du das sogar ohne es
zu merken gesagt ist die tatsache dass
provokationen am ersten in der lage sind
das zu vermitteln was ich fühle
diese provokation kann übertragen worum
es wirklich geht
provokation ist also auch hier teil der
kunst
[Musik]
ich habe gemerkt wie wichtig den jungs
rap ist aber auch dabei eine bestimmte
message rüberzubringen
aber wo genau verläuft dabei die grenze
ab wann wird rap strafbar
und wie das ganze außerhalb von spanien
aus ich suche noch einmal im netz
denn auch anderenorts wird diese frage
hat sich diskutieren
in england steht zum beispiel der 20
jährige digger die im zentrum der
kontroverse
er gehört zu den stars des uk tour einer
reform die immer wieder von den behörden
zensiert wird
sie befürchten einen zusammenhang
zwischen den steigenden
kriminalitätsrate um der musik damit den
songs geht es viel und gangs und gewalt
auch die garde ist wegen seiner gang
vergangenheit vorbestraft muss daher
sämtliche songs und videos bereit ich
prüfen lassen er ist auch darin
eingeschränkt was er bei seiner
vergangenheit sagen
[Musik]
seit wochen mit seinem management
kontakt will unbedingt mit ihm sprechen
aber in letzter minute ziehen sie zurück
es ihnen zu heikel
ich frage mega low was er von der
starken reglementierung der texte und
der gewaltverherrlichung der rapper hält
die gewalt findet statt es werden
täglich menschen umgebracht und wenn man
dann irgendwie sich wunderbar denkt ja
warum muss der orf immer gewalt
verherrlichten seien dann sage ich mir
also dann geh doch mal bitte da hin und
fragt sich wo die leute herkommen was
sie erlebt haben
die wut ist nicht durch den web
entstanden sondern eben durch ungerechte
strukturen und es ist ganz wichtig dass
das ein dass es dafür ein bewusstsein
gibt und dass irgendjemand das
ausspricht und wenn die rapper
diejenigen sind die das tun dann ist das
schon mal eine sehr gute sache weil das
bringt gesellschaftliche diskurse in
gang
klar die rapperin fühlen sich sonst
nicht gehört
die andere seite sagt sie machen die
situation noch schlimmer
aber ich finde jeden text vor
veröffentlichung erst mal zur prüfung
vorlegen zu müssen über die partie ist
schon krass
oder was meint ihr ich kontaktiere ein
professor für straf des teams per mail
der sich mit gang kriminalität und
gewalt im zeitalter von web und social
media beschäftigt ich will eine
einschätzung
was bringt die staatlichen eingriffe
überhaupt und ist rap selbst am ende
auch teil des problems
[Musik]
bei meinen recherchen stoß sich darauf
viele andere länder in den rap in
konflikt mit dem gesetz kommt vor allem
dort wo ein ganzes regime druck aus wut
in russland zum beispiel wo der bekannte
rapper face sagt er werde konstant
überwacht
[Musik]
in deutschland kommt es immer wieder zu
diskussionen zum beispiel rund um den
song nach wie vor vom berliner rapper
tarek von kiz im musikvideo tötet der
mehrere menschen die deutliche
ähnlichkeit zur fdp politiker
das löste zwar ein shitstorm aus aber
rechtliche konsequenzen für den rabatt
ist nicht in spanien wäre das vielleicht
anders hier in barcelona im stadtteil
garcia sind die ausschreibung der
proteste das paar flog deutlich zu
spüren
ich will wissen wie das thema jetzt noch
in den köpfen ist und komme mit ein paar
jungs ins gespräch ich denke dass die
menschen hier in unserem viertel grad
sich das problem sehr bewusst und
generell dafür sind das heißt gegen das
was geschehen ist und dafür zu
demonstrieren das ist alles für eine
rückkehr ins mittelalter in dem sinne
wenn jemand was zum könig sagt dann ich
denke es ist richtig für die welt ob man
will oder nicht denn wie er schon gesagt
hat carlos l ist lediglich ein bild aber
was dahinter steckt ist viel wichtiger
es ist die meinungsfreiheit und die muss
respektiert werden
wir werden sie jetzt nicht aufgeben klar
ist hier geht es um viel mehr als nur
musik aber welche macht hat wirklich
gesellschaften zu verändern und welche
verantwortung geht damit einher
um das einzuordnen wenn ich mit heidi
süßwaren die sozialwissenschaftlerin hat
selbst rap und forscht dazu
sie publiziert unter anderem zu sexismus
und sozialer ungleichheit im und durch
wer also im prinzip muss man ja sowieso
das was im web passiert doch jetzt in
den staaten entspannender in deutschland
immer im verhältnis sehen zur
gesellschaft in der werkstatt findet und
wenn in der gesellschaft politisch
gesandte dinge passieren
dann nimmt das web wird auch was sagen
als als der wenigen musikgenres immer
wieder auf was muss man beachten oder wo
sind die risiken die man auf der einen
seite würde ich sagen entspannen
runterkommen es ist nur web musik keiner
hört ein text geht raus und knallt
jemanden ab ysy auf der anderen seite es
ist extrem erfolgreich es reproduziert
wirklich rückwärtsgewandte geschlechter
modelle gerade im mainstream
das sind alles schon so
diese struktur merkmale die man einfach
schon so internalisiert hat und so in
kopierter dass man die gar nicht mehr so
mitbekommt dass sich schon kritisch
gleichzeitig möchte ich eine lanze
brechen für rap weil ich schon dass du
der meinung bin dass es kein anderes der
art politisches musikgenre in
deutschland gibt es in regelmäßigen
abständen politische missstände und
soziale ungerechtigkeit und rassismen
thematisiert wie rap und auch die
gangster auch wenn er sicher nicht jeder
text gefallen muss kommt man dafür in
deutschland in der regel nicht in den
knast
anders als zum beispiel sparen da gibt
es jemanden der mit mir spricht der
schon für seine texte verurteilt wurde
[Musik]
alexis 26 macht wie pablo selb
politischen weg wir treffen uns kurz vor
der korona sperrstunde in seinem viertel
er hatte lange gezögert mit mir zu
sprechen am ende stimmt dazu weil ich
kein spanischer journalist bin und weil
er die aufmerksamkeit nutzen will um
druck aufzubauen
ich will wissen ob marcels inhaftierung
angst gemacht hat und warum justiz auch
auf ihn aufmerksam wurde
als ich meine benachrichtigung und die
nachricht von der verhaftung von partner
bekommen habe es schon verdammt
es war hart eine person zu sehen wie du
kennst der mann befreundet ist und die
das gleiche tut wie man selbst
natürlich ist es überhaupt nicht
angenehm mich hat es stark getroffen
thema in den ganzen medien zu sagen als
wäre ich quasi an terroristen möchte
klar welche schule wenn jemanden
einstellen der terrorist ist der
terrorismus verherrlicht was sagen sie
zum terrorismus zum lehrer sein
oder wer wird akzeptieren dass so eine
auch alex wurde aufgrund seiner texte
schon einmal verurteilt acht jahre
berufsverbot eine bewährung und eine
geldstrafe
und das obwohl er im untergrund wird mit
seiner musik verdient er kein geld
er rappt weil er wütend ist auf den
start wenn ich zum beispiel sage wir
brauchen geo team für die polizei
führerschein wenn ich sage dass die für
das oberkommando der polizei routine
verdienen das sind beispiele für die
verurteilte muss einfach verstehen dass
ich mit einer politischen botschaft für
viele mag
die routine für die polizei zugegeben
das kind kraft aber gerade hier in
katalonien haben die heftigen polizei
dazu bei den von abhängigkeit demos ihre
spuren hinterlassen
der konflikt mit dem staat hat hier eine
andere härte erreicht als vieles was ich
aus deutschland kennen alex betont noch
einmal er wolle keine menschen umbringen
lassen es gehe ihm um den kampf gegen
ein ungerechtes system sowie
offensichtlich vielen rappern rund um
den globus wie und wo dabei die grenzen
der kunstfreiheit verlaufen
das scheint oft nur ausgekämpft werden
zu müssen auch die spanische regierung
hat übrigens inzwischen eine reform des
knebel gesetzes angekündigt
wie genau das aussehen soll ist noch ob
auch bei uns in deutschland wetten
raptexte 2 und hitzig diskutiert was ist
für euch
wo zieht ihr ganz persönlich die grenze
schreibt eure meinung in die kommentare
lasst uns hier diskutiert das war es von
mir bis bald
[Musik]